[Music]
this morning in our final dish of 2022
we celebrate with John George Von
rishton better known as John George the
French native has restaurants across the
U.S and around the world this year Jean
George has taken a lifetime of travel
and experiences and put it all Under One
Roof at New York's South Street Seaport
that's where we sat down for a special
New Year's Eve meal but first we took
some steps and some bites in and around
the tin building
do you remember the first time we walked
in here when it was done and ready and
you saw yes what was that moment like
for you the tin building by John George
is more than 53 000 square feet of
dining and drinks groceries and
accoutrement you can get everything from
wood-fired pizza to Crepes caviar to
cookies
in short it is the ultimate place to wet
your appetite I know we haven't been
together long but I love you right now
with John George's my personal tour
guide it's a good thing I brought mine
all candies chocolates so here we have a
egg sandwiches
into foreign
wow
thank you
John's restaurants on nearly every
continent but wanted something that
encompassed all of his experiences Under
One Roof he and his team spent 10 years
renovating what for more than 100 years
had been New York's Fulton Fish Market a
historic place for many including Jean
George I remember when I arrived in New
York in 1986 the next morning I came to
the fish market and it was a wild place
it was starting at 12 o'clock at night
until six seven in the morning so the
sun was going up next to the Brooklyn
Bridge it was magical so this is
for the first one Fish Company
when you turn around ah it's a wine bar
with the chocolate and cheese this is my
favorite place here really
in Japanese is a sushi bar
of course have you seen me say noted
I love that about you so fresh you said
madai from Japan
so or King Simon from New Zealand I know
that I've had this before
[Music]
with one floor complete we move upstairs
we're only halfway there
mind blown truly
which way do I go I call it the
Frenchman's though he calls it Italian
with a Twist while across the way is a
vegan and vegetarian restaurant called
seeds on Weeds
I like that around the corner the
Mercantile East Market has Specialties
like miso and soy sauces from across
Asia and there's more than meets the eye
if you know where to look on this little
sign here it's a little Speakeasy it's a
fantasy of mine love it yeah
it's called House of the Red Pearl that
is very James Bond
s
it's a very special
it's like a sultry look to it the
Speakeasy is open to the public but Chef
whisked me away to the only place that
isn't his private dining room where we
sat down for the most decadent dish of
the year with samplings from each of the
13 eateries in the tin building I think
it's the first time I see it all
together
including glazed Maine Lobster noodles
with ginger scallion and green chili the
Chinese noodles that are fried first
then dried and then I boiled and mixed
with lobster or some chili a little
spicy I was just insane I just got a
kick of the spice which is great black
truffle pizza and lemon pizza with Meyer
lemon fresh ricotta Fontina and Parmesan
oh my gosh it's fresh it's really fresh
just that Citrus with the cheese is
amazing a raw bar Tower and a sushi
platter
we have a king madai
tuna kingfish
fluke money
salmon eggs from the brasserie a wood
grilled wagyu rib eye and a truffled
gruyere cheeseburger on a puff pastry
bun you know in us even sometimes
dancing until two and then I like to eat
my burger on the end
charred squash served with a Mexican
inspired mole sauce Molly has a little
bit of chocolate in the spices yeah you
know I would never have thought to do a
mole with that it's like a United Nation
yeah we have food from everywhere
you clearly love to entertain I'm an
entertainment does it feel like work no
that's absolutely nuts
I mean if you find your passion or
nothing you I'm the only one running to
work in the morning you know that's
great never presented I never step away
from it it's my life yeah which wasn't
what the family business was for you no
actually it was a cold business
and the cold business went to gasoline
okay Central Heating and then solar
heating so hit it every minute of it so
when I was 16 my parents took me to a
three Michigan Star Restaurant
on I didn't know you could do
a living out of food because we never
went to a restaurant it was like
the ballet of the waiters the food I was
like oh my God
changed my life you know I find my
passion over dinner it seemed
appropriate then that for dessert chefs
served up a chocolate passion fruit tart
how is it oh my God the fruit oh see for
me the last day a lot about
Let It Go Let It Go that's right
[Laughter]
you started a new year so
for an Entertainer like John George his
work is about more than satisfying a
craving it's about feeding the soul
meaning there's no detail he doesn't
think about 2 20 23. fantastic
happy and healthy New Year thank you for
spending 10 years creating this
wonderful place thank you very much
Cheers Cheers
[Music]
Happy New Year
nice I know you couldn't tell I loved
every minute of that tour with John
George and you heard him say cheers all
about Indulgence indulge in a little of
what he sent over these cookies are
Delicious By the way at the tin building
one of the things he wanted he wanted
people to enjoy it the way he did the
full and fish market for him was like
you know all hours everybody was in was
there and it was busy and chaotic and
that's what he has sort of created there
by having a space that is open from
Seven till all hours of the night
basically and when you're there you have
to be Elsa
right let it go let it Let It Go and Let
It Go and enjoy